[موسيقى]
لا أستطيع أن أقول إن
صيد الأسماك كان على رأس قائمة
هواياتي ،
وهنا اختفت أي فكرة عن أدوات الصيد عالية التقنية
مع نسيم البحر ، فماذا أفعل؟
يد آه ، سنقوم
بالتجول بشكل
صحيح ، لذا الأمر بسيط جدًا ، إنه مجرد
خطاف
، نعم خط رسمي
لا لا لا
لا لا ، لا نستخدم الشبكات التقليدية
طوال الوقت ،
نذهب أنا فضولي لمعرفة ما
سيشعر به  كما
لو كانت سمكة أو إذا عضت سمكة ،
لا ، لا أعرف لماذا أفعل ذلك ،
يبدو الأمر وكأنه نوع من الأشياء التي ربما ينبغي عليك
القيام بها ، حيث
كنا نصطاد لنحو نصف ساعة
وهو بالطبع لا يعد شيئًا من حيث شروط الصيد
وليس لدينا أي وقت للخطة ، إن
الطعم علي على المحك ، ما الذي
تفعله
الآن ، لذا فهو يعض الآن ،
نعم أنت متأكد من ذلك ، لا يمكنني الشعور بذلك ، نعم ، يمكنني ذلك ،
نعم
، لقد ذهب الآن أوه أوه أوه هنا  نذهب
لا ، لقد ذهب كما أقول لم
يكن الصيد أبدًا أحد أعظم ما أحب
[موسيقى]
لا شيء أتذكره مرة أخرى بـ Uncerta
من أجل العيش هنا تحت رحمة البحر ،
ما هو على استعداد لتقديمه
وليس ما تتوقعه ،
إنهم يأتون لرؤيتنا آه ، انظر
إلى هذا ،
فأنا أرى سبب عدم إهدار الوقت على الماء لسكان جزر المالديف
أبدًا ، أوه
هم  إعادة جميلة بعد كل
ضجيج وهولابالو القوارب السريعة
والطائرات البحرية
، يوم من الصيد يتحدث عن مجلدات إلى
قلب هذا
المكان وهو بالفعل غذاء لروحك